I grew up thinking of farms as places
with red barns cows and gray-haired men
with overalls I never thought about
where the vegetables fit in or what
would happen when the gray-haired men
turned grayer as I and everyone around
me continued to grow up and depend on
farms for food I also grew up thinking
that I might become an artist a model
a violinist
a comedian or even a fairy princess
anything but a farmer
until now
there have been incredible advances in
technology over the past Century some of
which are growing population could not
live without but some of these are
asking our bodies and the environment to
compromise more than they can through
farming I have learned that we all have
choices when it comes to our food our
bodies and our environment things do not
have to be the way that they are
research has proven that people are
their happiest when they are part of a
strong community and when they help
other people I have seen this happen
time and again in multiple farming
contexts and with every age group Rising
with the sun working with whatever
weather has been dealt eating food that
has been grown with such care such
passion and hard work and doing this
with other people creates a sense of
purpose a sense of connection a sense of
happiness
in so many ways this seems small a
little farm in a little town somewhere
in Canada
but it's not small it's big
have you ever heard of the butterfly
effect basically it's about how small
things can impart big change and
unimaginable and unpredictable ways
these large-scale implications of a
small farm are not always so Apparent at
first it starts with the small lessons
Tomatoes aren't always red some are
green purple yellow and orange too
cauliflower can be purple and corn
leaves make beautiful music when the
wind blows through them winter squash
grows in the summer
from here we not only learn to look far
enough into the future to anticipate the
Harvest of a ripe fruit but to the
Harvest of healthier communities and
localized Food Systems as well
so why this video
I am asking for your support this may
not be the most conventional way to
fundraise but as an organic farmer I can
be a bit unconventional
for more information about the farm
about where exactly your money would go
or to view additional resources please
visit my page on indiegogo.com if you
believe in the butterfly effect in being
a part of strengthening small businesses
empowering Youth and supporting
Community then consider making a
donation no matter how small trust that
a single donation like the flap of a
butterfly's wing can create meaningful
change
thank you